Elon Musk here I recently purchased
twitter.com comedy is free and hate
speech but but not like too much hate
speech you know so that advertisers
don't leave some people are saying Elon
you paid too much for Twitter um I did
that all as a meme but look I'm gonna be
honest Twitter's in trouble based on
several phone calls I'm in today we need
to make Twitter profitable as profitable
as possible so that I can sell it uh and
not too much of a loss for the next few
months look out for these interesting
Twitter developments development number
one blue check Elites are going to have
to pay eight dollars this will
effectively separate those who are
normal from those who are willing to
give me Elon Musk uh money for something
uh that is essentially worthless
development number two Cash for Gold you
send us gold we give you cash that's
it's that simple finally our most
valuable and important development is
do you do you like do you like me do you
think I'm cool
I mean it wouldn't hurt for you to tell
me more